tywin's a great character people talking
about about him as being you know the
villain I'm not sure that he is Tywin's
one of those characters that you love to
hit love to be intimidated by this is a
part which is just absolutely Charles
goes down to the very essence its core
when Tywin was skinning a stag remember
that Charlie dance had talked on I'm
just the coldness of that and the
precision with eking the way continued
doing one thing while delivering this
you know astonishingly brutal lecture in
in power politics this Sun that was
fantastic as a character study to watch
that as an actor it's a master class
with like all of the lights and the crew
and everyone shooting that scene for a
long time that was like yeah pretty
impressive I mean you've got to be very
dedicated to your job Evans an awesome
character you know there's no one in the
world to prepare better than Charles
Townes
I loved about this is the metaphor when
it was butchering the deer and season
one you know obviously the high sign up
for our theaters a beer when he rides an
on on horseback and black were very hit
awake the horse [ __ ] on the floor
yeah that is great talking about [ __ ] it
was a great scene where timing comes in
to the throne room on a horse who else
could do that but him and of course his
horse [ __ ] on the floor at the very
before you kept saying could anyone else
get away with it
no that was that was great I mean it's
wonderful isn't it you know
that was a terrific scene to shoot
because you know I'm an actor we love
showing off and to actually ride into a
room for the people on the back of a
horse is quite something the trophy has
insisted to believe with Tyrion as well
where he basically isn't often to him it
doesn't mean anything to him you know
that's very sad that's also incredible
it's incredible acting the problem with
Tywin and Tyrion is that he's not
perfect you know and if he'd had his way
he would have just let him float out to
sea when he was born
having the scene and and he's telling
him that I wish it you had never been
born you know you you're the only reason
you're alive is because you share my
name and that's about it
it was one of the most horrific things
I've ever seen on screen that father son
and some of the best acting I think I've
seen period anywhere time and of course
it is very clever but it was interesting
to see him being outfoxed by a child and
away because ayah was right and his nose
all the time now what do you make of
that there were times when you know she
was coming she was wrong footing tyranny
but I think she commanded his respect
because of that how fun was it tricking
Tywin yeah I think it was great I really
loved the scenes when I first read them
Tywin just think she's a nobody and you
know there's something a little bit
different about her but I don't think he
really suspects that she's Robb Stark's
younger sister he reminds me of like a
headmaster you really hit but somehow
respects at the same time that sort of
thing I think I might have had a a Tywin
figure in my life at some stage I think
anything with Charles dance is amazing I
just think he can make you know the
artisan just make like walking to the
park look like you know wolf on Wall
Street tyrant is just doing what he has
to do it's a feudal society that he
lives in and he has to retain his
position
and he can only do that from being
strong and ruthless I'm afraid for my
money he has no redeeming qualities he's
he's just an awful man he's treated his
children appallingly
the father has a lot to answer for my
favorite moments with Game of Thrones oh
heavens above
probably my death scene though I didn't
know about until somebody in the street
we've been reading all the books you
know it's got great deaths singing I
said Oh have I what is the manner of my
death
and he told me it's quite spectacular ha
ha ha